- So today Sinead and I are gonna speak
about how math are used to
model the epidemic of COVID-19.
But we're just gonna start
with a little bit of
background about ourselves.
So I'm Sinead, I'm originally
from Glasgow in Scotland.
And now I'm working at Columbia University
in New York as a postdoc.
And like Jeanne said, my research focuses
on using mathematical models to understand
how our immune systems
respond to virus infections.
- And I'm Chloé, and I'm
originally from Toulouse
in the southwest of France.
And I moved to New York early last year.
I'm also a postdoc in Columbia
in the same team as Sinead and
working on mathematical models
of the immune system as well.
- So just some information about me.
I've been working in New
York for two years now.
And usually I love to travel
so this is me and my boyfriend
on a trip to Scotland last summer.
But since the outbreak started,
we've been sheltering at
home with our dog Dixie,
and you can probably tell
that she's not really a fan
of posing for photographs
by her face here.
But she is very happy
that we're both working from home now
and can keep her company all day.
And in my spare time,
I've started taking an
online drawing class
just to improve my art
skills a little bit.
- And I moved to New York
City early last year,
I've been really enjoying
exploring the city,
you can see a picture
of my good friend Kalina
and I in Greenpoint,
where you have a pretty great
view of the skyline.
And since the beginning of the epidemic,
I've been staying with my boyfriend,
working from his place.
I'm getting to know his cat Lily,
and you can see it's doing well
'cause she's taking selfie with me now.
And I'm also cooking a lot
and I'm trying to find the
best cookies recipe ever.
And this is one of my
experiment from a few weeks ago
that you can see here.
- So before we get started,
we just want to let you know
that our presentation will
be a little bit different
from previous D4Ps,
because most of the
papers presented before,
used reasoning that was
based on experimental data,
but we're gonna present another style
of scientific reasoning
called mathematical
and hypothetical modeling.
And essentially what that means is that,
if you want to understand
a particular process,
you can use mathematical
models to simplify
and represent it.
And today, we're gonna show
how those simplified models
can be used to understand
the SARS-CoV-2 outbreak.
And so you may have noticed
that this style of scientific reasoning
has got a lot of media attention recently,
as governments and policymakers
have been consulting
with scientists and using
their mathematical models
to help plan pandemic response efforts.
So you may be familiar with terms like,
flattening the curve,
modeling the impacts of social distancing,
and the value of a
quantity called R0.
And we'll be discussing
all of these things today
as we go through the paper.
So here is the paper.
It's called "The effect
of control strategies
to reduce social mixing on outcomes
of the COVID-19 epidemic in Wuhan, China:
a modeling study."
So it's quite a complicated title.
But if you focus on the phrase,
control strategies to
reduce social mixing,
that essentially means the
rules of social distancing.
And so what the authors do,
is they use mathematical modeling
to explore what would happen
to the SARS-CoV-2 outbreak
when you lift the rules
of social distancing.
And the use of Wuhan in China
where the virus first
emerged as a case study.
And so you might be wondering, why Wuhan?
And an important point to know is
that this paper was published in March.
And at that time, Wuhan
was still very much
a global focus of the outbreak
and social distancing rules
had already been established there.
And so learning what might
happen when you lift those rules,
could help us understand
how epidemics will play out
in other locations as well.
And another thing we want to
mention about this paper is
that it's already been
cited over 170 times,
which means that over 170 other papers
that have been written just since March,
have either mentioned or used the results
from this paper in some way.
And that's a huge number
in just two months.
And it really shows how fast the pace
of research is moving in
response to the pandemic.
Another cool thing we want to highlight
is that all of the authors are
based in London, in the UK.
They have experienced
modeling infectious diseases
around the world.
And so some of the other
sightings that they've worked on,
are Ebola in West Africa,
Dengue in Indonesia,
Zika in Singapore and
Tuberculosis in Cambodia.
And so this just goes to show that,
mathematical modeling isn't just used
in the fight against SARS-CoV-2
but in the fight against
infectious diseases
around the world.
- Sinead just showed you
that this learning team has been working
on modeling a different
number of infectious disease,
and actually one of the first question
you could ask is, this
why do we use model?
Which is a legitimate question to ask.
So basically, when a disease
spreads in the population,
a lot of questions are raised,
and in particular,
how fast and why disease spreads.
And those questions are really important.
And eventually by
knowing a little bit more
about the disease, we can also determine
how to slow down the
spread of the disease.
And basically mathematical models
can be used to capture the
standard transmission process
and study which interventions can be used
and can be helpful.
And actually studying
infectious disease is not new.
And for example, one of the pioneers
in this field was John Snow.
So some of you may actually
be familiar with his name.
He's a famous character of
the Game of Thrones series,
but the real John Snow was
actually an English physician
in the 19th century.
And here is the real John Snow
and he's known for his
work on a cholera outbreak
that was going on in London in 1854.
And at the moment,
people didn't know where
the disease was coming from.
There was no knowledge about germs
and microbes as we know now.
And it was basically thought
that the disease was caused
by the bad quality of air.
But John Snow at the moment,
studied the pattern of infections
in London neighborhoods
and he understood, by
studying those patterns,
that cholera was transmitted by something,
by an agent in contaminated water.
And so that led the
government to take actions,
including replacing the pumps
and that overall improved the quality
of water people had access to.
And I wanna just quickly
mention some other pioneers
who studied infectious disease.
So here you've got Anna Wessels Williams,
and she was actually a New Yorker
and she was one of the
frontline scientists
working on measures of fighting
the pandemic of flu in 1918.
And you may have heard about this pandemic
'cause people have been
speaking a lot about it lately.
And here is Fe del Mundo
and she worked in the 50's,
on understanding the transmission
and the characteristics of
Dengue in the Philippines.
Dengue being a tropical disease
that's transmitted by mosquitoes.
- Okay, so now let's
get back to the paper.
And today we're gonna focus
on two of the author's main objectives.
So objective one, was to
use a model to predict
what would happen in Wuhan
if and when social
distancing rules are lifted.
And then objective two, was to explore
how transmission from children
affects the progression
of the epidemic.
And the reason that they
included this second objective,
is that when the work was carried out,
observations had been made
that children seemed to be less affected
by the disease than adults.
But it wasn't really clear
whether children were
transmitting the disease
as much as adults, which
is still the case now.
And so the authors wanted to see
how that could impact the outbreak.
But before we jump into the paper,
there are a few key terms
that we want to go through
that may be unfamiliar,
but they're used a lot in
the field of epidemiology.
And they'll become important
when we get into the details of the paper.
And so some of the things
we'll go through are the latent
and infectious periods, R0 and Re,
and then also what the
transmission rate is
and what a simulation is.
And so first, the latent
and infectious periods.
So if you think about someone
who's just been infected with the virus,
it takes some time for the
virus to enter their cells
and to grow in numbers.
And during that time period,
although they're infected,
they're not yet infectious.
And so they're not yet capable
of infecting someone else.
And we call this time
period, the latent period.
Then after some time,
they'll become infectious
and at that point,
they will be able to infect
or transmit the virus
to someone else.
And so then we see
that they've entered the infectious period
and they're capable of transmission.
And then finally, after
some point in time,
they'll recover from the disease,
or in very unfortunate circumstances,
will die from the disease.
And at that point, because
they're no longer infected,
and all transmission has stopped,
we see that they've entered
the recovered period.
And so another important term
that we want to go over,
is R0 or the basic reproduction number.
And its full definition is,
that it's the average number of new cases,
caused by each infectious person
at the start of the epidemic.
And it essentially measures the potential
for a disease to spread in a population.
So if you imagine that you're
the first person infected
with a new disease, then R0
is the number of new people
that you're going to infect,
and also the number of new people
that those people will go
on to infect and so on.
And so in this slide we showed
an example of R0 equal to two.
So you start with one infected person,
and then that infected person goes on
to infect two new people.
And then each of those two people goes on
to infect two more new people,
which leads to four people infected,
and so on, and so on.
And so in reality, you may find
that some people only affect one person
and maybe others infect three people.
But on average, we see that it's two.
And from the picture you
can see here very quickly,
we can build up to having a lot
of new people being infected.
And so one important question is,
how can we use R0 at
the start of an outbreak
to predict whether the disease
will successfully spread
in the population?
And actually, it's pretty simple,
because if each infectious person infects
less than one new person on average,
then the number of new cases will decrease
and the disease will fade out.
And so in other words,
if R0 is less than one,
the disease won't spread.
But if R0 is greater than
one, like in the example,
then the number of new
cases will continue to grow,
and so the disease will spread.
And this is just to give
you an example of how the R0
for SARS-CoV-2 compares to
other infectious diseases.
And so the value for this,
because we're looking at today,
is the use value of 2.5.
And you may have seen some
other values being used,
and that's because there
is some uncertainty
around the true number.
And this is partly due to the fact
that people use different
data to estimate these things.
But if we think about the value of 2.5,
we can compare that to other diseases
and we can see that seasonal flu
and Ebola both have values
that are less than 2.5,
whereas smallpox and SARS-CoV-1,
which was the virus that caused
the SARS epidemic in 2003,
they both have moderately higher R0s
between three and five,
whereas measles has a
much, much higher R0 at 15.
And it's worth just pointing out here
that R0 doesn't tell you anything
about how severe the disease is,
but just how well it spreads.
And so one quantity
that's very similar to R0,
which you may have also
heard about recently,
is the effect of
reproduction number, or Re,
or sometimes it's also called RT,
and sometimes just R.
And like R0, RT measures the
average number of new cases
caused by each infectious person.
But instead of being used at
the start of the outbreak,
we use it once the outbreak has taken off.
And so if you remember our
example of R0 equals two,
since it's at the start of the outbreak,
no one has had the disease yet
and so everyone is at
risk of being infected.
But if you compare that
same example for Re,
we can see that now on average,
each person is infecting less new people.
And that's because since the
outbreak has taken off now,
some people have already had
the disease and recovered.
And so at least in the short term,
they can't be infected again.
And so the value of Re, is
less than the value of R0,
because there are less
people available to infect,
once the epidemic has taken off.
And so one thing you might have noticed,
is that R0 is fixed at
the start of an epidemic
and doesn't change,
whereas Re can change over time,
as the number of people
who've recovered changes.
And so Re is also a very important measure
because we can use it at
any point in the outbreak,
to determine whether the
disease will continue to spread,
like we did with R0 at
the start at the outbreak.
And so if Re is less than one,
then each infectious person,
will infect less than one
new person on average.
And so the number of
new cases will decrease.
Whereas if Re greater than one,
then the number of new
cases will continue too.
- I think we have that poll now.
- Okay, so here's our
question for the poll.
The question is, imagine
you were the first person
infected by SARS-CoV-2 or Ebola,
to how many people would
you transmit the virus?
Is it less than two?
Between two and four?
Between four and six?
Or more than six?
So we'll give you a few moments
just to put in your answers.
Okay, that's great.
So I think most people have voted now
and it seems like, yup,
most of you got the answer right.
It's between two and four
'cause you saw that the
R0 for SARS-CoV-2 was 2.5
and for Ebola, it was two, great.
Okay, so one last quantity
that's also related to R0,
is the transmission rate.
And essentially for
each infectious person,
that measures how many people
that they will infect on each
day that they're infectious.
So for example, if I stay at home
and I don't come into contact with anyone,
and am infectious,
but because I haven't seen anyone,
I won't be able to actually infect anyone.
But if I decide to go out one day,
and I have contact with five other people,
like in the example,
and if the chance of infecting somebody
who I have contact with is one in five,
then overall, I'll end
up infecting five people.
And so you can see
that the transmission
rate not only depends
on the number of contacts that you have,
but also on the chance
that each of those contacts
results in transmission
of the disease.
And so as an example, at
the start of the epidemic,
we can link the transmission rate to R0,
because if I infect people
or one person each day
that I'm infected, so my
transmission rate is one
and I end up being
infectious for two days.
Then overall, I'll infect two people,
and so that would correspond
to a value of R0 equal to two.
- So the final term we
wanna go over is simulation.
And that term relates to how we use models
to make predictions.
So for example, if I wanna use a model
to look at how a disease will
spread in a city like Wuhan,
I need to know some of
the value of the key terms
like transmission rate or R0
that Sinead just introduced.
And really often we don't
know the real value,
but we have an idea of
the range of those values.
So for example, I may
know from other studies,
that R0 is somewhere between two and four.
Choosing values in this range,
so for example, here I choose R0 equal two
and then I run the model
and I look at what happens.
So here for example,
I look at the number of cases over time
to see how the outbreak progresses.
But as Sinead just
said, R0 is a key term..
Is very likely to change the outcome.
So here's the number of cases.
So what I can do after that,
is taking R0 equal to four instead of two.
And then I run the model again,
and I see how that modifies the
progression of the outbreak.
And so each time we run the model,
we call that a simulation.
And then R0 is called a parameter
because it's a value we can modify
each time we run the model.
So other important parameters,
are actually the transmission rate,
the infectious period
and the latent period
that were just explained.
Okay, so now that we went
through all of the key terms,
let's go back to the paper.
So that's just a reminder
of the key objectives.
The first objective happens
when the social distancing
rules are lifted.
And then the second objective,
is to explore how the transmission
from children can affect the
progression of the epidemic.
So we'll be speaking a lot about models.
So let's have a look at
what this math model is
and how it's built.
And something I wanna mention
before I go through it,
is that the model that we present,
is the one used in the article.
But it's a classical model
that is used by a lot of researchers
to model infectious disease
transmission in populations.
And so it would be the same
principle for other disease.
So that's basically the model.
And what we do is,
basically we divide the
population into different groups.
And the groups depend on the
different stages of the people.
So the people in white
here are the susceptible,
which is basically all of us
last year regarding COVID-19.
It means that we've never seen the disease
and we can catch it.
Then we've got the people
in pink and in red.
And those people are
infected by the virus,
so the virus is in their body.
But only the people in
red here are infectious,
which means that they can transmit
to the susceptible people in white.
And the infected people who
cannot transmit the virus,
so the people in pink
here, are called exposed.
And finally, in blue,
are the people who recovered
from the infection,
or unfortunately, in some
cases, die from the infection.
So now that we have our groups,
you may wonder what are
the arrows in the group
and what they mean.
So let's take a simple example.
So at the moment, it's
very likely that myself,
am in a susceptible group, in white.
And so you can imagine
that tomorrow for example,
I go do laundry in the
basement of the building,
and I chat with my neighbors.
But the issue is my neighbor is infectious
and he doesn't know it.
And he also had a very bad
idea of not wearing a mask
when he go to do the laundry.
So by being in contact with him,
I catch the virus and I become infected,
without being able to
transmit the virus right away.
So that means that I'm moving
from the susceptible group
to the exposed group.
And that process of moving
from one group to another,
from the susceptible to exposed,
is defined by the transmission rate,
which as Sinead explained,
is determining, on average,
how many people my neighbor
will transmit the virus each day.
And unfortunately, I'm part
of those people that day.
Then I stay in this exposed stage.
So I am infected by the virus,
but I cannot transmit it yet.
And that amount of time is
defined by the latent period.
So after that period,
which is gonna last around,
let's say, five days.
I'm gonna become infectious,
and then I can transmit the disease.
So when I am infectious,
I can transmit the virus to
other susceptible persons
if I don't stay home, for example.
And then finally, I'm
able to transmit the virus
during the infectious period.
And after that time, which
lasts roughly seven days,
I'll hopefully recover.
So now you know that the
arrows represents how
and how fast people move
from one group to another one
when in the model.
And basically what we do with the model,
is making sure that everyone
belongs to one of the group.
And every day we look at what
has changed in the population.
So today, I'm in the susceptible group
and my neighbor is in
the infectious group.
And tomorrow, the model which will predict
that I am in the exposed group,
and so on every day.
And so what we are interested in,
is how many new cases
we will have every day,
Which is basically how many people move
from the susceptible to
the exposed group everyday.
And then finally, there's something
that we haven't mentioned yet.
But you all probably know that,
not everyone develops symptoms
when they are infected by the virus.
And so we can divide the
group of infectious people
into two additional subgroups of people.
So we have the people with symptoms
and the people without symptoms.
And for example, based on
the first observations,
we think that children will
have less symptoms than adults
and so they will more
likely be in that group
than the other one, with symptoms.
- Okay, so Chloé just
went through the models
that the authors use,
and now I'll go through
how they incorporate social
distancing into that model.
But first, going back to
the transmission rate,
we said that it depends
on the number of contacts
that each person has,
and the chance that
each of those contacts,
actually results in a new infection.
There is something that we didn't mention,
is that the number of
contacts the person has,
can depend on their age.
So for example, if we think
about what happens during the day,
we might expect that working adults,
will mainly come into contact
with some other adults,
whereas children may come in contact
with lots of other children if
they go to school or nursery.
And the elderly may come into
contact with some other adults
and some other elderly people,
for example, if they live
with partners of the same age,
or if they live in a care home.
So these differences are
actually very important
when you start to think about the impact
of different social distancing measures.
For example, if we think
about closing schools,
then that will mainly reduce the number
of contacts among children.
Whereas if we introduce social
distancing in the workplace,
so-called workplace distancing,
then that will reduce number
of contacts mainly among adults.
And then if we introduce social distancing
in the community or
general social distancing,
such as closing public spaces,
or stopping people visiting
their friends and family,
then that will reduce the number
of contacts among everyone.
But here we've shown how it can impact contacts
of the elderly just as an example.
And the main point here,
is that different social
distancing measures
will reduce the number of
contacts in different age groups.
And as a result,
will reduce the transmission
rate in those age groups.
And so incorporating social
distancing into the model,
is the same as reducing
the transmission rate
in each of these age groups.
And as Chloé said, that's
just like reducing the number
of people who move from
that susceptible group
into those infected groups.
Okay, so how does this
all relate to the paper?
Well, in the paper,
they explore what would happen
in four different social
distancing scenarios in Wuhan.
So the first scenario, in purple,
is if no social distancing was in place,
so essentially daily
life goes on as normal.
The second scenario, in blue,
is if schools were closed,
and workplace distancing was introduced,
but only for a month between
January and February.
The third scenario, in orange,
is if general social
distancing was also introduced,
though all three measures
are in place from January
and then this goes on till March.
And then scenario four, in yellow,
is the same as scenario three,
except instead of ending in March,
it runs all the way through to April.
And so there are a lot of details
about these different scenarios,
but you don't really need
to remember them all.
The main thing to remember is that,
scenario one is when there's
no social distancing.
And then as you move up from one to four,
the measures get more intense
and are in place for
longer periods of time.
But once each of these rules are lifted,
life goes back to normal.
And so for objective one,
the authors wanted to explore
what would happen in Wuhan
when in each of these different scenarios.
And so before we show you what they found,
I just want to take you
through the axes of this figure
'cause there's quite a lot going on.
So along the x-axis we have the time
since the virus first emerged in Wuhan
and it starts in November last year
and it runs all the way through
to December of this year,
because the authors wanted
to look at what could happen
in the coming months.
And then along the y-axis,
we have the number of new
cases per day, in thousands.
And so for example,
a value of 60 would mean there
were 60,000 new infections
on that day.
And then finally,
the colored vertical
bars represent the times
when those different
social distancing scenarios
were in place.
So there's no purple bar
because there was no
social distancing in place
in the first scenario.
And then as you move from
blue, to orange, to yellow,
you can see that the
scenarios were in place
till either February, March or April.
And so now we've got our bearings,
we can look at what the
model simulations look like.
And again, there is quite a
lot going on in this figure
so if we first just focus
on those first two curves,
scenario one, in purple,
was when there is no social distancing
and then two was when schools were closed
and there was workplace distancing,
but only until February.
And you can see that by adding in
just a little bit social distancing,
we managed to reduce the number of cases
at the peak of the outbreak.
And that's that day
when you have the highest number of cases.
And we also managed to
delay the peak a little bit.
And so essentially, that's what we mean
when we say flatten the curve,
that we managed to reduce
and delay the peak of the outbreak.
Now, if we focus on the last two curves,
scenario three was when
general social distancing
was also added, and this
was in place till march.
And then scenario four was the same,
except it was in place till April.
And now you can see we
make even more progress
towards delaying and reducing that peak.
And so these strict social
distancing measures,
improve our ability to flatten the curve.
As I'm sure you know that,
this is important because
it gives governments
and health systems more time to prepare.
And it means that there
will be fewer patients
for them to treat when the
outbreak's at its peak,
which means there's less chance
of hospital systems being overwhelmed.
- Okay, so now let's look
at the second objective
of the paper.
And let me walk you
through this slide also.
So here the question is how transmission
from children affects the outbreak?
And now what we're gonna do is,
just focus on the best case scenario,
which is the fourth scenario in yellow,
that Sinead just presented,
that was able to delay
the epidemic the most
and substantially reduce the
number of cases at the peak.
And so in order to measure
and quantify the impact
of taking this strict
social distancing measures
on the outbreak,
the authors look at how
many cases can be avoided
until the end of 2020
by applying this strict
social distancing rules,
compared to the worst case scenario
where nothing would have been done,
which is the one in purple, the first one.
And then since we have uncertainties
on how infectious children are,
in each graph, the authors
have run a different simulation
to explore what happens
when children are as infectious as adults,
and that's the graph on the left,
or what happens when
they are less infectious,
which is the graph on the right.
So now, let's just focus
on the graph on the left.
So children are assumed to
be as infectious as adults.
And the y-axis here,
is the percentage of cases avoided
by using the most intense
social distancing measures,
compared to doing nothing.
And the x-axis is breaking this down
among different age groups in Wuhan.
So you can see that the biggest percentage
of cases which is here and here,
is around 50% or more,
and that was avoided in young people
and also the elderly, so here.
And this is particularly
important for the elderly
because they are the ones
who are the most at risk
of severe disease.
So what this graph show is that,
by introducing strict
social distancing methods,
around half of the case,
we could have expected by doing nothing
or avoided in this vulnerable population
by doing these strict
social distancing rules,
and that's really great.
And then if you look at
the graph on the right,
the authors assume children are
less infectious than adults,
and you can see that this
certain cases of avoided cases,
jumps from around 50
persons to 80 persons.
And that's a big difference.
And that shows that it's really important
to understand how much children contribute
to the spread of the disease.
- Okay, so now that we've
gone over the main findings
from the paper, we can go
back to these two objectives
and see how the authors answered them.
So for the first objective,
they wanted to use a model to predict
what would happen in Wuhan
if and when social
distancing rules were lifted.
And what they found from the first figure
that we discussed is
that social distancing
helped flatten the curve.
And so at this point
you could rightly tell
is that you would have predicted
this from the beginning.
But where the models really help,
is by putting numbers behind this idea.
So it's important to know, for example,
how many cases we might expect each day.
And by how much time we
might delay the peak,
so that hospitals and
governments can plan accordingly.
And where the model also helps us,
is to compare different scenarios
and to put a number on
how much we might gain
if we use those stricter
social distancing measures.
- In the second objective,
they aim at exploring how transmission
from children affect the outbreak.
And what they found from that
second graph I showed you,
is that if children are
less infectious than adults,
we can avoid even more cases
with those social distancing rules.
And again, the model helps putting numbers
behind this concept.
And there's still uncertainty actually
about how children are
affected by the disease
and so this study highlight
that we need to do more
research about that.
So one thing to keep in mind,
is that the study was made in Wuhan.
And the social mixing in Wuhan,
may be different from other cities
like New York, for example.
And so the results from
the same type of model
in New York will be different.
Another point is that this
study was conducted in March,
when social distancing rules
were still in place in Wuhan.
And now we know that those
rules have been lifted
and so the situation in
new Wuhan has changed.
And if the authors want to
incorporate these changes,
they will need to gather more data
and update the model
to reflect the more recent circumstances.
So keeping those two points in mind,
I just wanna quickly show you
how the model can be
applied in other contexts.
And here what you can
see is some researchers
from Columbia University who
are projecting the number
of new infections in New York City,
and they actually regularly
update the predictions
using the collected data.
So here for example,
I took what they did on May 3rd.
So they projected what
would happen eight weeks
after May 3rd, by using data
that was collected before.
So the blue part correspond to the data
and it's actually the
same in the two graphics.
What changes is the scale of the y-axis.
So here you see this 30,000 is here,
while in this graph, it's here.
A different scale, but it's
actually the same data,
it's the same graph, the one in blue.
And then the yellow part,
which is on the right of
this dash line here and here,
it correspond to the
projection under the worst case
on the left, meaning that
all of the restrictions
are lifted in New York
and if we keep the restrictions
as they are at the moment,
so on the right.
And then these two yellow lines here,
in dash and in plain line,
they just correspond to
different simulations
that the authors made,
that are based on different hypothesis
on the aspects of the
transmission of the virus
that we don't fully know.
So they just took different branches
as I explained at the beginning.
And then something else
that we could do with this type of model,
is studying other type of interventions
in addition to the
social distancing rules.
So for example, if a
vaccine become available,
we can look at how the
progression of the outbreak
is modified by introducing
the vaccine in the population,
using the same type of model.
So basically, what we did at the beginning
of the epidemic, is looking
at how the disease was spread
in a population that is
completely susceptible.
And that's that type of
population here on the left.
And now what we're looking at,
is what happens when the transmission
is in a more heterogeneous population.
So here what's happening now,
where we have people who
are still infectious,
people who've recovered,
people who were also still susceptible.
We can also look at how the progression
of the disease will be modified
and hopefully controlled,
by vaccinating a certain
amount of the population,
here in yellow.
And we assume that those
people who are vaccinated,
they're not at risk of
catching the disease
if the vaccine is efficient enough.
And then something, finally
that Sinead and I wanted to highlight,
is that the models depend
on the accuracy of the data.
So you may have heard
that at the beginning,
the models were not good.
But there was not enough data
to make really great predictions.
And we saw we can refine the estimation
and the predictions that
we do with the model
by gathering more data on the epidemic.
So on that note,
we just wanted to provide
some additional resources,
where you can look at up-to-date models
and see how they're using real
time outbreak forecasting.
So for example, the first tool here,
is an interactive tool that
is created by the authors
and also other scientists
they collaborate with.
And you can actually
modify some parameters
and explore by yourself the impact
of different social distancing
measures on the outbreak
in different countries.
And the second link,
it's actually the CDC website
where you will have results
and predictions from different
models, from different teams.
And something we wanna conclude with,
is that it's really important
to look at the results
from different models based
on different assumptions,
different data, because
public health decisions
are not taken only based on
the results of one model,
but they're more based on
the combination of results
from different studies
with different models.